As we go to our next game,
Swipecasting. Swipecasting.
-I've got some work to do here.
-Now,
I'm gonna show you a series
of eligible bachelors
and other types of
eligible things, and I want you
to ring in to swipe left
or swipe right,
but you have to tell us why,
all right?
That's the most important thing.
First up, Urkel.
Here he is. Yes, Liza.
Swipe right.
Nerds eat mad (bleep).
All right.
(cheering and applause)
(laughing):
Oh!
Next up, Jar Jar Binks.
Jar Jar Binks.
Yes, Dom.
Uh, swipe right,
'cause I'm an ear guy.
-(laughing): Yeah.
Points. Points. -Oh.
Uh...
Uh, next up, Gronk. Huh?
-Liza.
-Swipe right.
I've always wanted to make out
with someone
that was like a cute Shrek.
-Yeah, points.
-You know?
(laughing):
A cute Shrek.
Next up, Oprah.
-Mamrie.
-Uh, swipe right
'cause I want to show her
the cover of my O-face Magazine.
Yes, points.
-Mmm.
-Yeah.
And she's eating bread again,
and I love bread.
What would the cover
of that magazine look like?
-Oh, no, no, no.
-Okay, all right.
And finally, Drake.
Yes, Mamrie.
Uh, swipe left, because
da grass is always greener.
Oh, what?!
Oh...
Oh, my stomach.
Oh!